what is cancer what are its causes the
treatments and the methods for
prevention welcome to our class on
understanding cancer at the genetic
level we have a world-class team of
experts here ready to teach you about
all the exciting developments in this
area what we're going to learn in this
class is why is cancer genetic disease
some cancers run in the family they're
inherited other cancers arise strictly
from new DNA changes in any event all
cancers have at least one genetic
mutation that's responsible for driving
cells to grow uncontrollably we're gonna
learn about the mechanisms involved in
cancer initiation progression we're
gonna learn about the mutation events
we're gonna learn about tumor
development you're gonna learn also more
about evasion spreading and metastasis
as is fundamental and seriously
problematical as cancer grows and
spreads we're gonna learn about the
targeted treatments that are responsible
for targeting these various pathways and
genes and their products it's really
only in the last I would say half a
dozen years the field has really taken
off an amazing speed the ability to
sequence DNA and to map regulatory
regions the ability to analyze genomes
wasn't even possible a few years ago so
this is now an incredible time and it's
just amazing and exciting to be part of
it